ننتقل الان الى مدينه هاتاي التركيه
ومراسل العربيه
لمتابعه عمليه انقاذ الطفل في احد المباني
المنهاره زيدان هل تسمعني الان
نعم
قبل دقيقه نعم قبل دقيقه وكما تشاهدون تم
اخراج شخصين على قيد الحياه الكاميرا
ستحاول المشهد في الاسفل تم نقلهما الى
سيارات الاسعاف كما تتابعون والان عمليات
الانقاذ ما تزال مستمره هنا في هذا المبنى
تم اخراج شخصين ما زالوا على قيد الحياه
وهناك شخص ثالث يحاولون التاكد من حالته
الصحيه على ما اعتقد انه طفل
ساحاول الاقتراب اكثر
لكن ما نحن متاكدين منه هو اخراج شخصين تم
في البدايه اخراج شخصين على قيد الحياه
والان عمليات التاكد
هناك طفل على ما اعتقد طفل ما زال على قيد
الحياه نعم
سنحاول التاكد من هذه المعلومه منذ بدا
بدات عمليه الايقاذه زيدان
عمليه الانقاذ مستمره وصلنا الى هاتاي قبل
دقائق حتى الان هنا في هذه
العربه او في هذه النقاله شخص خرج حيا
والان تجري عمليات الاسعاف الضروريه وتدخل
العاجل من قبل الفرق الاطفاء او عفوا فرق
الاسعاف
هل لديك من معلومات حول طبيعه هذا المبنى
زيدان
نعم هذا المبنى هنا في وسط مدينه هاتاي
قبل قليل وصلنا الى هذا المكان لا يوجد
لديك تفاصيل كامله عن طبيعه المبنى لكن ما
نشاهده الان
ان هناك فريق من
كرغيزستان هو الذي يقوم بعمليه الانقاذ
هنا البحث والانقاذ
كما تشاهدون الان ما زال هذا الشخص على
قيد الحياه سيتم نقله مباشره الى
سياره الاسعاف
بعد ان تم اجراء عمليات التدخل العاجب
الان يجري نقله مباشره سيتم نقله الى احد
المشافي خرج حيا بعد ثلاثه عشر يوما قضاها
تحت الانقاض
اذا تم اخراج شخصين على قيد الحياه
وانتشروا جثه ايضا من هذا الموقع
الذي تشاهدنا
يتحدثون افرق لانقاذ الان تخبرني بان وجود
تم انتشار ثلاثه اشخاص على قيد الحياه
والعمليات ما تزال مستمره هنا في هذا
الموقع
اذا ثلاثه اشخاص على قيد الحياه خرجوا من
هذا المكان